i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but
so many of you emailed me about it that
i i do want to say a little bit about it
um
yet uh two days ago
uh the florida republican governor ron
desantis uh appeared with some high
schoolers
and behaved in a just disgusting manner
he went over to them and he told them
almost like in a bullying way
take the masks off check this out
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take care
honestly it's not doing anything and we
got to stop with this theater so you
want to wear it fine but this is a this
is ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf
[Laughter]
now um so i mean like listen first of
all what a leader right
we're not against masks we just don't
think the government should be telling
you to wear them but i'm gonna tell you
not to wear them and i'm here from the
government come on dude and uh when you
look at this guy
i understand why 28 of cpac wants this
guy to be the republican nominee because
he's sort of like a more aggressive
more competent more dangerous version of
trump this guy is trump but slightly
less nuts in in the way of
being cartoonish but very very dangerous
now one kid decided to keep the mask on
and some people are saying oh wow what a
hero whatever
what's wild is
this is not even the craziest part
of desantis's very very strange
appearance at uh in in florida at this
workforce education event
he also bizarrely attacked france kind
of playing up this story that
france is is basically weak and [ __ ]
like we're still doing these stupid
tropes yeah ron desantis is doing them
a lot of other places around the world
they just fold the minute there's any
type of adversity i mean can you imagine
if he went into france would they do
anything to put up a fight probably not
um and so those folks um you know are
stepping up but it's a there's a lot of
problems i think between now and then
and i think unfortunately it's going to
end up very very ugly
i mean guys the this is a governor whose
analysis of the russian invasion of
ukraine is
the people in ukraine are are actually
uh
doing something they're trying to resist
[ __ ] french people wouldn't do anything
i mean these are some of the most base
course
tropes that have been floating around
for 20 years remember john kerry back
when he ran against
george w bush for president in 2004
um the whole idea because kerry speaks
french the whole thing was okay carrie
is a [ __ ] because he speaks french
these are such
dumb tropes and they still exist with
people like desantis and and the the
people that follow desantis here's one
last clip and here's desantis asked did
you agree with anything joe biden said
in his state of the union and he kind of
hems and haws
and gives a very weird answer
um
you know i mean i think
i i have to think about
some of the stuff
well i mean
i agree you know if you think about what
they've done
fauci is in the witness protection
program now they don't want him out they
no they they've never supported any if
you listen so i guess what desantis is
saying it's a very backhanded compliment
he seems to be saying
the aspect of the state of the union
address that i agreed agreed with
is that biden didn't mention fauci
and fauci wasn't there i guess i mean
it's a it's a really backhanded
compliment it's really not a compliment
to them they never supported all these
policies that were so destructive now
it's like you know we all want to be
like florida all of a sudden and nothing
has changed of course many many many
things have changed when you look at
case numbers when you look at
immunity it's not even worth it okay the
the takeaway here is
desantis bullying children
into taking off their masks
vile
but everything he said at this event
reminds me of how
trump was really really bad
if this guy is actually the nominee and
potentially becomes the next president
of the united states
it will be worse than with trump this
guy is just as wacky
but he's more competent and more able to
do
all of the horrible things that he would
try to do let's hope it does i'm not
saying i'd rather trump be president
it's a crazy thing to say but in some
way it might be less bad if trump were
president trump at nearly 80
more incompetent
and even presumably lower energy just as
a result of his age
seems less dangerous than ron desantis
as president of the united states it's
my view as of today if you agree
disagree either way let me know what you
think trump or desantis if you knew one
of them would be the next president let
me know on twitter where you can find me
at deepakman
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 percent off when you go to all
form.com pacman the link is right
underneath this video